being a content creator is one of the
most Recession Proof business models
there is in fact I've created passive
income that can weather any storm the
nation's big Banks say they're preparing
for a recession do you anticipate a
recession fear uncertainty and doubt and
if you're consuming that it can infect
you like a virus the truth is content
consumption is skyrocketing friend this
is a recession-proof business model
listen I understand that you should have
a healthy level of skepticism when you
hear a term like Recession Proof it can
be easy to say oh that's just kind of a
hypey title that's trying to get me to
click on the video or the podcast but
the truth is being a content creator and
creating content is one of the most
recession-proof business models there is
in fact in this episode of the think
media podcast I'm going to be talking
about my eight question Recession Proof
test if you can pass all eight of these
tests then you my friend have a
recession-proof YouTube channel I'm also
going to be talking about powerful
lessons that I've learned in the 2008
recession so that you can learn from
those and thrive in any economy all
right so let's dive into my eight
question Recession Proof test the goal
here is that you want to either answer
yes or the quality of your answer to
each of these questions will determine
basically a score of how recession-proof
your YouTube channel is so here's number
one are people still going to watch
content this year answer they are and
this was an easy one because this one
doesn't have to do with your actions or
your channel the truth is that content
consumption is skyrocketing you know
there's 2.6 billion monthly active users
on YouTube right now and the demand for
good content is just off the charts ever
since the pandemic people have become
more familiar and into the smartphone
consumption of their content Smart TV
consumption you know it's interesting I
watch my parents in their 70s they are
now YouTube consumers and they learned
that when they had a lot less to do
during the lockdowns and so we continue
to see that people are going to watch
content but the truth is that in down
economies should that be where we're
headed did people watch more content
they're looking for more chance to
escape more opportunity to learn skills
more opportunity to watch content online
when I interviewed Patrick Bet David in
Miami recently I said like what are your
tips
going into a recession for business
owners and he stopped me and he goes for
business owners or for Content creators
and I go actually for our community
content creators would be a better
answer he goes oh well for Content
creators this is an opportunity he's
like some Industries some businesses
they might get crushed but this is
actually why but content creators it's
the most recession-proof business model
when restaurants got shut down during
the lockdowns content consumption went
up
when people are on Hard Times viewing
content goes up and he said just along
with alcohol sales and uh you know drug
sales that ultimately content you know
entertainment actually does not go down
this is one of those things where back
in the Great Depression they actually
studied that makeup sales didn't go down
that people were still willing to spend
money on makeup because they wanted to
look good they wanted to feel good and
it was one of the things that they did
not cut friend number one are people
going to still watch content the answer
is yes so that's a massive opportunity
to create a recession-proof YouTube
channel number two what content are they
going to watch hmm good question because
there are certain topics that rise in
popularity makes me think of do it on a
dime I was able to interview her years
ago on a different show and today she
has over 2 million subscribers where of
course she didn't start there and when
she started was in the midst of a
recession but her chosen topic was very
strategic do it on a dime couponing
Frugal Living how to save money so what
content are people going to watch if
it's entertaining if it's helping people
escape great what kind of skills or
things are they going to be interested
in you will probably want to Pivot your
content calendar and your video topics
you should always be pivoting them
according to the psychology of culture
and more importantly of your ideal
viewers so to the degree that you are
clear on making strategic content in
reaction to or responding to or with
awareness of what's happening in the
macro culture the better your YouTube
channel will perform in any economy
number 3 what topics will rise in
popularity in 2023 you might say well
Sean how would I know this I mean it's
just obviously it might take some
speculation maybe but it also has to do
with data or it has to do with just
understanding that one of the things
that does rise in popularity will
unemployment go up and there's a lot of
tech companies at the time of recording
this podcast a sales force just laid off
like 7 000 people uh 10 of their seventy
thousand Workforce you know Facebook's
done layoffs some people think that if
we go into a recession many people think
we're already in one it's going to be a
white collar recession so it's going to
be tech jobs more and maybe not the rest
who knows I'll leave that up to the
economists and to the financial and you
know experts in those Arenas but if
people are disrupted from their job the
pursuit of learning new skills goes
through the roof learning new hobbies
goes through the world Ruth sometimes
people are on unemployment they're
looking for their next thing but they're
also finally they might have a room to
breathe and they want to get into
fishing or they want to get back on
their motocross bike or they want to
start working on that car that's in the
garage or they want to start doing those
DIY projects people by the way looking
to earn extra money
Etsy start a side hustle learn something
very specific like affiliate marketing
learn how to freelance teaching
freelance teaching software a couple of
our video raking Academy students teach
canva I'm sure a lot of people do do you
know how many users of canva there are
such a massive opportunity with not huge
channels they're getting brand deals
they're getting paid by Brands they're
getting paid by canva so there's just so
much happening I'm just asking you to
think more strategically what topics are
going to rise in popularity this year if
you cover the best topics like if you're
going to score yourself on a one to ten
of how successfully you react to these
questions you know a perfect score would
be an 80 out of the eight questions and
if you're like I don't know I'm making
the wrong topics that's a one are people
going to watch content one one if they
stop watching but they are going to win
two right so that's a 10. and so we get
as high as score as possible which
brings us to number four are people
going to spend money this one a lot of
people get hung up on because they think
oh my gosh we're in a recession and by
the way watching the news can be
incredibly harmful to you when it comes
to being in the right mindset for
dominating on YouTube or an online
business because a lot of times even if
someone goes did you see how much credit
card debt is rising you're like oh my
gosh you know the world's melting so you
go I'm just gonna sleep in a little
longer I'm just discouraged what's the
point what's the point of even trying if
if your reaction to content you're
consuming is that then you need to
change the content you're consuming
because it might be like oh my gosh have
you seen Consumer Debt rising in in
America and you go well great at least
consumers are spending money on
something like I'd like a piece of that
debt I mean whatever of course like you
of course ethically care about the
individuals but there's always two sides
of the equation but here's the most
important one are people going to spend
money yes in fact I will score this one
for you this one's a 10. and the mistake
people make is just because your
neighbors change their spending habits
or you change their spending habits
there are billions and trillions of
dollars being transacted all the time
there is someone that's still buying
something still clicking on an affiliate
link still purchasing something still
wanting to learn something just because
it's not you I actually coached the
think media team this a lot I say do not
project your money mindsets on other
people because if you think our course
is expensive maybe that's a better
answer it's I understand it's a stretch
for some people but it's a drop in the
bucket for many people it's a friction
free purchase when they understand the
value of it see it depends on the
individual and so the real question is
where is the money being spent and how
can you get in front of that the real
question is are people going to spend
money the answer is yes what are they
spending money on can I get in front of
those topics and can I also protect my
mindset so I ultimately have a
recession-proof YouTube channel number
five is what are they going to spend
money on our goal here
is to create assets on YouTube that pay
us whether we work or not
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
let me explain and give you the next
couple questions I'll recap on one are
people gonna still watch content yes
what content are they going to watch
make strategic content number three what
topics will rise in popularity this year
make those topics number four are people
going to spend money yes number five
what are they going to spend money on
number six what topics have verifiable
interest and number seven what are the
best Evergreen Topics in my Niche I
wanted to pair these last couple
together because if people are still
spending money which they are on topics
that they have verifiable interest
meaning people are always interested in
them and then if they're Evergreen
topics what is that Sean I grew up in
Seattle where we have evergreen trees so
that means it doesn't mean whether it's
a good economy or bad economy the trees
are still green whether it's summer
spring winter or fall this trees are
still green that's why they're called
Evergreens many of us experience Seasons
where the leaves fall off these
evergreen trees a lot of times they're
pine trees or whatever they are green
all year long your goal is to create
Evergreen YouTube videos around
verifiable interest things that people
are always interested in on something
that people are always going to spend
money on so it makes me think about
Jennifer from the sewing report she's
about to hit 100 000 subscribers she's
one of our video ranking Academy
students and one of her videos I think
it's her most popular video is about a
brother embroidery machine
the video is four years old it is in the
description is an Amazon affiliate link
and so people that are looking for by
the way an affordable embroidery machine
not the highest end model still 650
dollars they are able to ultimately
watch this video and the video is four
years old and it continues to get views
it has a couple hundred thousand views
and so I dm'd Jen and was like hey how's
this video doing and she said I bought
this machine for six hundred and fifty
dollars it's paid me over four thousand
dollars is how much I've earned on the
Amazon affiliate program but she made
the video four years ago now she makes
all kinds of YouTube videos on her
Channel but this particular video has
verifiable interest it's Evergreen no
matter who you are think about it the
people who lost their job and the people
who didn't lose their job someone's
buying an embroidery machine someone is
starting to finally get back into their
embroidery or sewing or DIY Hobby
somebody got promoted even if somebody
else lost their job and it is the end
users
choice to go to YouTube search for
something they're interested in find a
video that is quality that is
educational that compares to things that
is helpful click on the link and you to
be the beneficiary of a commission on
that sale so that's your earning money
whether you're working or not friend
this is a recession-proof business model
that's not the only way to do it but if
you to break down the strategy make a
video that is search based or intent
based and people keep watching it for
years and in the description of that
video is a link to products that people
are interested in purchasing then you're
bringing in income and by the way this
is the model this is the story of think
media this is why whether we post new
videos or not we don't just keep getting
views which by the way the cool thing
about YouTube is Will advertisers
continue to advertise on YouTube videos
meaning you earn money through
monetization Sean I'm not monetized yet
that's cool we'll help you get there
like once you get there you can earn
money I saw somebody who just was blown
away she shared on Facebook I can't
believe YouTube paid me sixty five
thousand dollars this year in ad Revenue
she goes it's not even her main business
I never would have thought that YouTube
would have paid me this my friend
Jessica and it was never my main thing
but this is blowing my mind and it was
up like 300 from the year before see you
might go oh there's a recession man it
matters who you're listening to oh
everything's going down oh did you hear
the news oh I can't believe everything
that's happened around me it's fun fear
uncertainty and doubt and if you're
consuming that it can infect you like a
virus on the flip side if you realize
people are still spending money people
are still watching content people are
still making purchases and I'm
positioning my videos in front of that
and I'm serving people and I'm helping
and I'm answering questions and I'm
teaching skills and I'm reviewing
specific products and as a result I've
created passive income that can weather
any storm people are still spending
money Brands which they pay YouTube and
then YouTube gives you about half and so
when people are at home even if they
can't purchase something through an
affiliate link or buy a course or buy
something they can watch free content
and you monetize in the middle and so if
you just up your views you have so much
freedom and control doesn't matter if
you get laid off and you can't get on
you know commute to work and do all that
thing from home you can build
recession-proof income but it's
important to be making videos about the
right things that have verifiable
interest on Evergreen topics lastly
number eight what video topics have the
highest earning potential what are
people going to spend money on what
topics have verifiable interest what are
the best Evergreen topics or also what
topics have the highest earning
potential this can tap into because not
every video is Evergreen right meaning
it's not the some people go to extremes
Sean all you talk about is like you
should make review videos with affiliate
links
um no but I mean you can have you can
think whatever you want that is one of
actually 16 different strategies that
are kind of a part of our proprietary
process that's only one piece of the
puzzle I do believe you should make a
lot of Evergreen videos videos that are
viewed for weeks months and years and
years and years to come so you're
getting views constantly but I also
think you should jump on Trends or post
videos that maybe don't have a long
shelf life it's not either or it's both
and people go should I do shorts or
should I do longer videos both well what
should I do live streaming or should I
do shorts how about both what should I
do like affiliate marketing or should I
do get at YouTube ad Revenue uh how
about both I mean why are we there are
better strategies for different niches
but like it's not either or it's both
and like let's do it all and let's
figure out how to do it smartly and
intelligently so that it's all woven
together in a cohesive strategy what
topics have the highest earning
potential there are certain topics on
certain channels I'll give you one
example I heard from Shelby Church who
does Airbnb a lot she has a Palm Springs
Airbnb maybe you've heard of her Channel
she talks a lot about Airbnb tips and
hacks I think she got a brand deal for
touring and trying different airbnbs
cool well she brought a guest on her
Channel and interviewed somebody else by
the way which speaks to the fact that if
you had I want you to stay focused but
if you had a broader video podcast topic
Channel different guests are going to
focus on different things well She
interviewed somebody else and they
talked about Amazon Ecom which would be
like Ecom stores Drop Shipping and her
CPM was over a hundred dollars
now I don't know what your CPM is if
you're monetized but a lot of times the
average CPM on YouTube is two to five
dollars we're a lot higher at think
media and I think we range from
18 to 25 to 30. but if you look in
certain that's the average so you can
look at certain videos and it's much
higher here's the point what topics have
the highest earning potential if you're
going to be more purposeful this year
and if you're going to position yourself
to prosper and Recession Proof your
channel you got to do it at a higher
level of strategy friend it is not by
accident that'll happen and it's not by
just making whatever videos you feel
like with some random approach it's
about being more strategic more aligned
planning it out better and being
informed about how YouTube works and how
you know the different topics and
different cpms and different niches
which we don't have time for that today
but definitely subscribe if you're not
subscribed to the think media podcast
give us feedback wherever you listen and
let me know if you've been getting value
and some of the topics you'd like us to
cover in future episodes and I want to
say I appreciate you and I will connect
with you in the next episode
foreign